joining us now
a guy who plays for one of the best
teams in the national football league
trying to get back really are they one
of the best ones you're just gonna say
that i'm just gonna say that they're not
even in the playoffs they are one of the
best teams in the nfl they were racked
by injury this year and look at what
they
how are you buddy i'm doing great man
thanks for having me uh it's awesome
just to be here uh on the show and he
started off just so people too he was
like i'm really happy to see you guys
he's like i really want to play in one
of these damn super bowls
he's he's his mind is in the right place
that's right and so many guys come
through and say that i really wish i
wasn't available to be here this week
i'd rather be at practice or at the team
hotel but i mean you guys had one of the
craziest years i've ever seen i've lived
in and around pittsburgh my whole life
and just it's like everything that could
go wrong went wrong but you kept
fighting and fighting and fighting and i
think a lot of what you guys went
through this year is going to carry over
into next year just from the standpoint
of fighting through whatever rough spots
come up because they're inevitable yeah
i mean i think for us you know we had a
defense that was unbelievable to help us
you know get through this season
uh i think the the trade for fitzpatrick
was amazing i think he's been a dominate
guy since you know he's been here uh and
then like i said on the offensive side
we face so many injuries holy cow you
know back to back like uh to the point
where like you know second week we lost
ben and then mason's out now we're
playing with devin and then now devin
now we're going back from mason and
uh it's it's been a tough one but like
you said we were still able to pull out
and had control of our destiny but fell
short like he mentioned a crazy year out
of that we didn't even mention his wide
receiver coach passed away in training
camp daryl drake who was one of my
favorite coaches ever at the university
of texas which that hurt r.i.p to daryl
drake but like
speak about mike tomlin and how what
what is his effect when all this turmoil
is going on and how he leads you guys
it's so crazy because you know
as a young dude i kind of like sit back
and i watch like how these guys react
how the captains react how's coach
tomlin react
and for him it's more so like i mean the
standard is the standard you know no
matter who we have on the field let's go
out there and dominate
and it's so crazy because
all i can think about is like oh wow
like he's composed he's calm
every meeting you know he's not one of
those guys like freaking out like oh
like who's gonna play this week who's
played that week now he's let's go out
there and dominate right
what do you think about ben
roethlisberger's overall recovery from
what happened last year with the elbow
injury what are you hearing from him or
anyone else about his ability to be good
to go ready to go the same old ben
starting into 2020. um you know just
talking to him that he's very positive
he's so excited to come back you know
he's it's been one of those years like
he was so excited to play with us this
year uh that you know he missed it and
for him you know he was always around us
even when he was hurt you know after
week two he traveled with us yeah he was
being a great you know being a coach to
all of us being a great guy so uh i know
this year he's gonna be super excited to
come back and you know come out here and
dominate and i'm excited because you
know a guy like him you know i need him
on the field well that's what i wanted
to say i know i know that's what i mean
because to to awful what mike said like
did this year make you appreciate ben
moore
i mean i just honestly it's every time
i'm not in it without him you know it's
tough you know
you do appreciate a guy like that a
quarterback who's a hall of fame
quarterback one day and you know yeah
like i said this year has been so tough
you know going against the double teams
going against uh the best the best
corner you know and not being able to
have someone who can like out a little
play or change it up get help yeah by
the right spot so yeah
yeah i mean
off of that what did what did you learn
about yourself this year you were a
marked man you know the antonio brown
wasn't there and you know of course he
ragged on you a little on social media
and all that you're always professional
but what did you learn about yourself
man i learned about myself is that you
know i faced a week where i was out for
five weeks you know i think mentally uh
it kind of took a toll on me because
like man like you understand how to come
back from that and stay positive and
that's what i learned about myself my
body yeah you know
i'm still young so for myself it's like
man i want to play it for a long time so
i take care of myself my body but i
think majority of all this to happen is
this season is that you know anything
can happen and no matter if that's what
happens you still have control of your
future and you know like i said this
past season you know we came a long way
yeah and i'm going to ask you about
antonio brown and i don't want to dredge
up old stuff but i really am curious
we've seen
things from him this year
that we don't know him we're concerned
and we're concerned and how much of what
has happened
over the course of the past year is
something you look at and say that's
even a different guy than what i knew
behind the scenes i mean is he is what
we've seen publicly what he was always
like and we just never knew it or is
this something different than what
you've experienced um it's
definitely you know something different
you know for myself like what you guys
are you guys are concerned i'm concerned
too yeah right uh
in the possible way of that like i mean
it's tough for a guy you know uh you you
you take away his his job i mean his
what he's been doing since he was a kid
yes and his passion so they take that
away and it's tough the situation he's
going through uh being a guy looking
from the outside in like like how you
guys are i was like wow that's a
different dude that you know playing on
the field how he was
okay i'm sorry
i got a rhythm here i thought we had a
brother i did i didn't usually every now
and then
in four days
i do i want to ask him this though who's
the best receiver in football right now
like in your eyes when you look at it
right now i know you think you're
awesome and you're capable of being that
but who's the guy you look at right now
it's like kind of
top of the mantel right now michael
thomas yeah you think so yeah has a
similar style to you yeah and i would
say like i mean his cash radius is
unbelievable right um you know he's i
mean yeah for him to have over 100 what
20 catches you know this 100 40 140 plus
is unbelievable right but he's a guy you
know who's you can put the ball anywhere
he's going to go get it yeah
he's definitely guy i like to watch he's
your guy i got you
so uh from the quarterback standpoint i
mean you've got three guys who can play
we talked about ben roethlisberger but
what what kind of surprised you from the
undrafted guy devlin hodges who nobody
knew anything about it played at sam i
always said it's samford not stanford uh
what what impressed you about him this
year aka duck duck
it's so funny because like he said in
football he's throwing a duck which is
like a bad bug but for him it's like
duck he's and he's it's always stuck
with him uh what what surprised me a lot
was that like he was able he had
so much confidence and swagger
coming into every game he was like in a
huddle like you can feel that with him
and i think that was his biggest thing
is that the whole offense was like oh
yeah this dude very confident
uh
he kind of had like a certain accident
so it was kind of hard for us to like
hear him in the huddle uh duck like
he's at the casino playing with casino
money right because he
got a thousand dollars for his tiny
bonus and basically he said this here
deserves 500 000 chips what can you do
with it can you perform can you go out
there and dominate can you win games or
are you going to lose it all so right
he's one of those guys man that he
surprises a lot all right tell us what
you're doing with gatorade and bolt 24
here yeah so both 24 um it's basically
has electrolytes my favorite my favorite
flavor is uh
watermelon and sea salt so
basically it's a filled the drink off
the field yeah um when i'm competing on
the field i use gatorade right off the
field i'm drinking uh both 24. and it's
lit i love it man some good stuff yeah i
mean this looks like the type of thing
you'd want to drink leading into a game
right to make sure you're totally
hydrated are you a guy that like needs
to get ivs ever during the game or
anything like that uh honestly all
depends like if i'm playing
in arizona like somewhere hot you might
need anything you might need it right um
but more so you know i was just stick
with it that's when you know you're a
freak mike all right because like guys
like you and me we don't cramp up but
like when you have lots of muscle and no
body fat they cramp up it's just a
different guy different human you guys
gave the 49ers everything they could
handle before anybody realized the 49ers
were any good this year early on in the
season you had the 76-yard touchdown
reception during that game what stands
out now thinking back at that that
experience you had against the 49ers
um i mean honestly like that one i was a
good game you know for us to go out in
san fran and we felt short man it was a
good game you know we could have had
them um
but that defense and our offense uh they
they make plays they make their plays
and i'm super excited to see what
they're going to do against the chiefs
off us because that's a dominate offense
too um so who wins who wins yeah come on
man gatorade ball 24 who wins 24. i'm
going 35 28.
and he seems to win it i'm not saying oh
what come on you're picking the score
but not a winner huh you're picking 35
28. yeah and i don't know
what are those two one of those yeah one
of those teams are gonna win we know
yeah yeah you're welcome you're welcome
what are you guys going for i i well i
mean i'm i'm i'm rooting for the niners
and i think the niners will win you know
i i went to college with kyle shanahan
the head coach asked about his tattoo so
let's do that too what is your tattoo i
got tattoos of a longhorn and some of my
homeboys
all right tattooed on his legs we've had
enough of you can you get out of here
please who are you going for you know i
he picked the chief i took the chiefs i
couldn't help it i i know i in my heart
the 49ers the better wait wait wait but
patrick mahomes there is something
special that he is doing right now and i
what he's using reverse jedi minds all
right let's talk about the game i wanna
you you're picking a damn game here
who's gonna win the damn game 35-28 who
come back all right
don't worry it's the first show i'm
actually saying it is good okay
49ers
juju's miss schuster wants the 49ers
let's light up social media
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports